victory have you ever been in the empire
state building before
ten-year-old victory brinker is hitting
all the right notes
[Music]
at one of the most iconic places in new
york city
[Music]
is opera hard
um
a little bit learning new songs when i
think i can't get them but i actually do
in the end
[Applause]
how does that feel when you finally
figure out a song that you didn't think
you could do i
i'm just like
you didn't give myself a pat on the back
and she deserves it guinness world
records just declared her the world's
youngest opera singer based on her first
professional contract which she got at
age seven did you even know what the
guinness book of world records was
before all this
not really probably not right
when did you know that you could sing my
mom said i had
perfect pitch when i was two
and then when i was six i asked my mama
she could show me a person you could
sing the highest note and i said i
wanted to sing opera and what did you
say i said okay someday
she says no i want to do it now
victory's mom christine says she's been
trying to keep up ever since she and her
husband eric adopted victory as a baby
she's one of 11 children
[Music]
her run has included performances on
world stages
[Applause]
and she recently sang the ukrainian
national anthem at a benefit concert
[Music]
what is it like to have a 10 year old
but also try to balance the fact that
she's still a kid you know what i'm so
excited by watching her dreams come true
and it seems like every time she sets a
goal
that goal comes true
[Music]
[Applause]
my hope is that
not only my other children
but other children around the world see
like everybody has a gift and victory
loves sharing hers
what do you want to be when you grow up
a singer you're already a singer well
maybe a better singer
just 10 years old but on top of the
world
for cbs mornings adriana diaz new york
[Music]
you